everybody please welcome Gary well my
wife and I just recently got married
she's perfect she's everything I ever
wanted a little tiny bit of trouble
bonding with my new stepson Lucas whoa
looks like found some earthworms good
talking to you buddy never really looks
me in the eye doesn't talk much
except when he yells at me to get out of
this room the Nerds using this weird
little go puppet thing I get this sense
that he's that he's evil incarnate
yeah remind me again how Lucas was
conceived you remember when I told you
about that crazy time in my twenties
where I joined that sort of like cult no
I don't think you told me about that big
doomsday cult believes a child will rise
up from hell to rule mankind and to
bring on the end of the world as we know
it I think we found that child and now
you're his stepdad there is nothing
wrong with Lucas he's very particular
job he did this to me you told me that
was normal that all kids are dicks
that's true kids are dicks men but this
is a different level
he's like top of the dick chain bro
this is bill bro you gotta relax man
and I relax we're in a cornfield so what
good thing has ever happened in a
cornfield al I don't know Field of
Dreams is pretty cool
[Music]